i want to follow up on yesterday's
discussion about
will they imprison women who seek
abortions and will they imprison or
attempt to imprison doctors who perform
abortions abortion has become a criminal
act in the state of south dakota south
dakota the governor of south dakota is
christy gnome christie nome is a big
trump tool a big trump suck-up
brown-noser and uh i want to focus in on
this question
of going after abortion doctors she did
a number of interviews on sunday pieces
of which we looked at yesterday but i
want to focus in on this issue of
imprisoning doctors now in multiple
interviews christy gnome went out of her
way to say we're not going to prosecute
women when it comes to abortion although
she left the possibility open if women
went to a different state where abortion
is legal and then come back to south
dakota that was a little scary yesterday
but she is making clear there seems to
be a significant appetite in south
dakota to go after legally the doctors
performing abortions let's take a look
at this first clip from face the nation
on sunday america has the worst maternal
mortality rate of any developed country
what specifically are you doing for
these women who not just when they have
the baby but during their pregnancy are
you giving them paid leave are you
giving them more health care rights in
your state are you giving them more
state funding what exactly are you doing
to keep them alive during their
pregnancy
you know i think that will be a lot of
the debate that will go on now in every
different state now that the supreme
court has made this decision the power
but she's not asking about the debate
she's asking what are you doing in south
dakota or to make these decisions really
goes to each individual state we've
already talked about that in south
dakota
what's the state's role in this and what
can we do to help these individuals that
are in these situations get them the
health care that they need to to help
their baby be born healthy and help them
be parents or help them choose a loving
family to raise that so a non-answer
okay so you're still figuring out the
specifics
okay well and you know this trigger law
was put into place years ago uh and it
was to go into it into law as soon as
the supreme court made a decision such
as it did so okay that's the debate and
discussion that we're having but i think
what's incredible and what's going on is
that the people will decide you know
elected officials at the state level is
who they'll be talking to to decide what
their state's laws look like south
dakota's uh obviously
you know under our past several years
and have stood for life and defending
life and i think we'll continue to have
those debates on how we can support
these mothers and what it means to
really make sure that we're not
prosecuting mothers ever in a situation
like this when it comes to abortion that
it will always be focused towards those
doctors who knowingly break the law to
perform abortions in our state the
criminal charges will be focused on the
doctors the doctors
um she then appeared on this week and
again she said if doctors knowingly
break the law they should indeed be
prosecuted let's take a look and what
about medication abortions the the
so-called abortion pill how will you
know if women receive those in the mail
and should those women be prosecuted
i don't believe women should ever be
prosecuted i don't believe that mothers
in this situation never be prosecuted
now doctors who knowingly violate the
law they should be prosecuted definitely
and the pill is okay you're saying the
pill is okay
again martha you're interrupting but i
am answering your question i don't
believe that that telemedicine abortions
are safe for individuals for women to
conduct at home many times they're doing
it unsupervised it's a medical procedure
and so i do believe that there should be
a physician supervision in place when
that is being conducted by any
individual all right so they're gonna go
after the doctors and they do seem to
sort of be cohering around this talking
point remember that early in trumpism
they weren't totally clear on do you
punish the women because there was this
time trump was asked about do you punish
the women and trump said yes do you
believe in punishment for abortion yes
or no as a principle the answer is that
there has to be some form of punishment
for the woman yeah it has to be some
form ten cents ten years
there you go and of course afterwards
trump was told no no no that's the wrong
talking point we don't say that we say
punish the doctors and by the next day
trump was saying no no i didn't mean i
didn't mean punish the women i didn't
mean that i mean punish the doctors now
two states so far minnesota and
massachusetts have seen their governors
sign orders protecting providers who
perform abortions for out-of-state
residents and that's one aspect of this
the governors of minnesota and
massachusetts have implemented legal
protections for reproductive health care
providers
who serve out of states out of state
residents who come to their state
seeking such care
uh that's one aspect of this but this is
sort of a different question which is
what about circumstances where you have
in-state everything is in-state what is
it that is going to be the goal of these
extreme right-wing states so this is
increasingly looking very much like you
know a market margaret atwood book quite
frankly that's what it is looking like
and uh it is scary stuff that we are
going to
continue tracking but it is not looking
particularly good